[Music]
earth
the only planet known to maintain life
a product of scientific phenomena and
sheer chance
this blue speck in space holds the past
present and future of our very existence
approximately 4.5 billion years ago the
earth formed from particles left over
from the creation of our sun
gravity drew these particles together to
form pebbles which then form boulders
and eventually the earth
at its heart is a solid inner core
covered by a liquid outer core
above this it's the mantle made of
flowing silicate rocks and a rocky crust
this rocky mass is the third planet from
the sun orbiting the star from an
average distance of about 93 million
miles
it's close enough to the sun to be warm
unlike the cold gas giants
but not so close that its surface is
exposed to extreme heat and solar
radiation as is the case with mercury
[Music]
earth's unique position in the solar
system allows it to house phenomena yet
to be found anywhere else in the
universe particularly liquid surface
water and life
according to one theory much of earth's
water is as old as its rocks both of
which having formed during the earth's
earliest days
because of earth's unique distance from
the sun the planet is able to contain
water in all of its forms liquid ice and
gas
rather than have them permanently frozen
or evaporated into space
but earth is the only known place in the
universe with liquid water on the
surface thereby having unique cascading
effects on the planet
it hydrates the land helping create
nutrient-rich soil
it collects and pools to form oceans and
fresh water systems
and it cycles upward to add moisture to
earth's protective atmosphere
and where there is liquid water
there is life
about 3.8 billion years ago in earth's
oceans
primitive life existed in the form of
microbial organisms
they and then suing billions of years
gave rise to a range of more advanced
life forms that thrived in earth's seas
lands and skies
as the only world known to harbor life
earth's biodiversity is expansive in
nature
an estimated 1.5 million species of
plants
animals bacteria fungi and others have
been cataloged with potentially millions
if not billions more
yet to be discovered
home to life and fueled by water
earth houses a unique global ecosystem
as curious and as grand as the
astronomical events that made them
possible
[Music]
[Music]
you